hello thanks for tuning in this is a
recording of an online training session
which was a beginner level class on the
node.js runtime this was a freestyle
interactive no slides just me typing
good and talking about it so let me
apologize in advance for all the speech
fillers I did however cut out the pauses
and the not useful parts so you can
watch the whole training here on YouTube
in one video it's 2.5 hours but it's
also available at Gia's complete dot-com
/gs and 19 where i split it by topic
into many videos you can also use the
timestamps links in the description to
navigate to the different sections if
you think of any questions while you
watch this please feel free to join the
JISC complete slack channel I just
complete that comm slash help and ask us
there I hope you enjoyed this class and
please share it with your network if you
know anyone who plans on exploring
nodejs let's get started so this is a
beginner class on node so uh no
assumptions about what you know about no
this is your first steps you know I
might be assuming that you know a little
bit of JavaScript and I am definitely
assuming that you know programming in
general so depending on on your skills
you might be you might be overwhelmed or
you might be disappointed with the
content we all have different skills and
this is natural but I hope most of you
will learn a few things anyway the class
is recorded so if you're lost in the
class go fill the gap in your knowledge
and come back and watch the recorded
class so my name is Sam Urbana and I
have been doing an ode for a while
currently I do note on the back end and
I do react on the front end but before
that I did a lot of other programming
languages I did some tickle Ruby I did a
lot of pee sequel but now it's all node
so and I am a really big fan of node and
everything all the libraries that make
that are added on top of the JavaScript
language which itself is very flexible
and it can do whatever you want it to do
so if you want to see the stuff that I
do I put links here feature links on on
this website and also I publish
everything I do on juice
complete calm so there are video courses
books interactive labs and a lot more
Jes complete calm by the way is a node
project so this is written in node and
react on the front end so I have been
hacking on this platform and it's really
fun so no no this node is really funny
well at least for me so let me set some
expectations about the class today
before we begin so this is not going to
make you an expert on node right this is
just your first step so just to get you
familiar to raise your confidence in the
platform and to get you started on the
right path to learning node because I
think a lot of people learn node the
wrong way they focus on the packages
that that comes with node or like that
the third-party packages that are very
useful but I think there is a big
benefit in to learning the internal you
know the the raw runtime before you go
and use the packages and and that
knowledge is gonna make you make your
use of those packages much better so uh
the one thing that you need for sure is
you need node so so if you have a node
version let me make this a little bit
bigger if you have a node version that
is 10 or higher you're fine I think it
will be fine too but if you have an
older node version so go ahead and
install node I encourage you to always
experiment with the latest and greatest
always have the at least the latest LTS
release but I actually do my development
on the current version even if it's an
odd number because odd number they're
not gonna be LTS so the way this works
is even numbers are LTS which is long
term support odd numbers are not so
right now we don't have any odd numbers
this is an even number but it's not
LTS yet it goes into LTS maybe in a few
months right so LTS will become no 12
will become LTS and they start with node
13 which is not LTS it's
experimental but always try to have the
latest node so that you get to start
exploring the new features that come to
language and so that you detect problems
going away because once you have the
latest if you using something that is
deprecated you're gonna get warnings and
it's just so much better overall but
definitely you have to test your systems
on the LTS that is that you're gonna use
in production right so for example just
complete comm is running right now on
this LTS so even though I develop I'm
and I add features on 12440 if I have it
I still locally I still switch things to
the LTS and test things on LTS just give
the whole system I go on the LTS before
releasing a big release so there are
tools for you to switch around so if
you're on Mac you should definitely have
homebrew homebrew is just the best way
to to this one the missing package
manager from node the best way to
install node and install many other
packages around node but there's also
nvm so nvm and there's a version for it
for Windows as well is note version
manager so if you have nvm install now
you can install node and you can install
different versions of node and you can
switch between these versions with the
press of a command so you get to
experiment with many versions of node
and that's that's great so what is what
is node exactly so when you have the
node command when you install node you
get three commands you get the node
command you get the NPM command and you
get the npx command all of these comes
built in with node
so node is a wrapper around v8 so v8 if
you're not familiar with v8 v8 is the
JavaScript engine not the juice the
JavaScript engine man the a JavaScript
the JavaScript engine that powers chrome
itself
so I am in Chrome right now and if I go
in here and open up the console and put
in any JavaScript so map the random for
example this is a JavaScript function
this is the JavaScript standard library
and chrome just executed that JavaScript
it did that through v8 so they extracted
everything JavaScript from chrome into
this v8 engine and of course every
browser has its ancient a different
engine so IE has a chakra there's chakra
there's spider monkey and and a few of
them now this is different then
executing a browser API so for example
if I do document dot get element by ID
right and or get element by whatever
that is that is Dom API that has nothing
to do with JavaScript it just have a
JavaScript interface so the this is a
JavaScript object document is a
JavaScript object but get element by ID
is an API on that object
same thing for things like set timer set
timeout set interval these are just
functions that gives you access to the
browser API these are not JavaScript so
set time app is not implemented by v8
it's implemented by the browser itself
so when you get the browser you have two
things you have v8 that runs everything
JavaScript and you have the browser
itself that runs everything DOM and
scrolling for example a handle scrolling
and handle resizing all of these events
are coming from the browser but here's
the thing everything runs in a single
thread so if you have a big giant for
loop in here that takes for a billion
times that loop is gonna block the
browser from doing things like scrolling
so if the for loop is running the
background the user cannot scroll your
page so it is important for you to
understand that this is a single
threaded environment however the browser
gives you an API a synchronous API is to
do things asynchronously so that you
don't have to block as a single thread
that you have the exact same story is
note so note just like the browser is
also a wrapper around v8 so you get to
execute so if we have the note command
just type in the note command node and
you get into this node that we call
grapple mode run eval print loop and
it's the exact same mode that you get
when you open the browser's console this
is also a rebel mode so in here you can
just do math dot random math dot random
and you get the exact same thing so this
is through node right but note we really
didn't do anything here know just pass
this command to v8 and v8 executed math
dot random v8 old node what the result
of math.random is and note printed it to
our screen right here so it's going back
and forth between node and mv8
so the question is why can't we just use
the eight directly you can of course but
no it comes with a lot of other benefits
around the the core standard library
right for example there is let's say
nationally to be server you can just
start using an HTTP servers there was a
package here called HTTP and it gives
you access to starting and HTTP server
and just like HTTP there is a lot of
them in fact let's take a look at all of
them right away so I'd like to point
your attention to a very very important
key on your keyboard ready it is the tab
key which is above the caps lock right
this tab key is important because of the
discoverability it gives you discover
discoverability powers so for example if
you are if array is a javascript class
right and it has many methods if you tap
DoubleTap on array dot so just do array
dot and double tap you get everything
that the available on array this is this
is a great discoverability because I
don't have to look up the things that
you can do especially if you have an
object like a mystery object that you
don't know what it is right so if you
have give you em and you don't know what
M is you can just see all the methods
that you can do
that look like em is an array because I
get to join and split than Keys and
splice and reverse so it isn't the radio
everything I can do and if you double
tap on an empty screen on an empty line
you get everything that you can start
with so all the JavaScript classes
you'll see here all the JavaScript
classes because you know it's a
wraparound JavaScript but also get
everything that is note so you see HTTP
HTTPS everything that starts with a
lowercase letter most of the things that
start with a lowercase letter here are
built in node so libraries that just
come with node you don't have to install
them those are things that you can just
start using so node is not a product
from chrome node is an open-source
community managed project but it uses a
product from Google which is v8 so v8 is
Google Google manages v8 and a node uses
v8 and it uses other stuff not just v8
for example it uses open SSL and a few
other libraries like that also you can
use node with other VMs so you don't
have to so there's an experiment or a
project where you can use node with
chakra which is the chakra core the ie
thing you know the powers IP edge so you
can run node without v8 with using
chakra core but by default when you
install node you get the node that's
wrapped around v8 ok cool so this list
here is really important in fact I would
say if you want a master node you have
to learn every single item on this list
I still I'm still learning new stuff
because new stuff comes all the time but
most of this stuff is JavaScript so if
you are not familiar with things like
date function not a number errors object
reflect simple these are JavaScript
things week map modern JavaScript right
it buffers array integers array floats
are a map promise regular Express
Shen's weeks that all of these are
modern JavaScript that you get to use
out of the box with note and the other
stuff that I'd like to point out to the
things that we will explore today we so
console is is a the same library that
the same you know object that you have
in your in your browser's console and
they try to mirror the exact same
interface for it in node but console is
not-it's not v8 it's written in node and
it's in the browser it's not v8 it's the
browser itself so today we're going to
talk about console we're going to talk
about the module object will mention
path will mention timers we're going to
talk about timers in general we're also
gonna talk about HTTP maybe a little bit
of net so there's a question what is M
p.m. how is it related to u node we're
gonna talk about that so you're running
node.js on shell on Mac what I should
run on Windows command prompt yeah so on
Windows you can run the CMD I would
recommend that you instead of CMD that
you install PowerShell so power fell by
in Microsoft is just a much better
terminal than CMD and by the way there
is a new terminal coming to Windows so
that is gonna be much better right but
PowerShell is the way to give for now
what is the IDE tool to cold the IDE
that I'm gonna use is called vs code so
it is probably the most popular editor
so if you wanna run anything I'm working
on we're gonna use it today and I would
recommend that you use it now in fact it
on Windows I vs code will give you a
better terminal so you can use the
terminal in vs good instead of using you
know the command prompt or anything all
right
what is I term to so I turn to is just a
replacement for the built in terminal
it's just a little bit better than the
built in terminal has better team ox
integration but you don't have to use it
but get put
only less explore it if you if you see
node is not a recognized command that
means you have to fix the path so you
have to put the node that was installed
in the path so we talked a little bit
about node rebel right node also is a
command-line tool so if you do node - H
you get everything that you can do in
node as a command-line tool we see a lie
of node so this is this is the CLI
that's gonna run a script in general but
it also you can use it with other
options so you'll see the usage here
node options and then you give it a
script if you want it to run a script
another another usage is node inspector
we'll talk about that how to inspect a
script in node and all of these options
just scan through them they're handy I'd
like to point out one particularly or a
few particularly helpful options if you
want to check the syntax of an ood file
and not run it just check the syntax -
see if you want to execute don't use e
use P because P is execute and print so
I'll sure let's let's explore that so if
I have no - P and you just give it any
JavaScript and it will execute it and
print it right away so that p is for
print a handy to just do things really
quick and and you and the other one that
i'd like to point your attention to is
v8 options v8 options so if you do - -
v8 options what you get is a big list of
all the options that node can pass to v8
so let's let's explore that I'm gonna
pipe it on less so that we get at page
by page so if he ate options so in here
you're gonna see a lot of things right
you're gonna see harmony flags you're
gonna see tracing flags and this listed
like 400 or 500 options that you can do
and and these are options that note pass
directly to v8 so if you wanna change
the way v8 be
change the or a little optimization of
the way v8 behaves or or change some
experimental flags right if you want to
experiment with you know webassembly
right here there's a flags from rep
assembly so most of these options are
actually advanced I just want you to
know of them so you can come to these
options and and and search if you if
you're looking to do party some
something particular with with the like
something advanced like like for example
if you're if you're to work with the
garbage collector in the a drive v8 has
a garbage collector you have some
options here to control the garbage
pointer to expose the garbage collector
to manually run the garbage collector so
you'll come here and see all the options
that you can do alright cool
another thing that you should be
familiar with is node environment
variables so when you run a node process
right when you run the node command
whether you put in a file or you just
run it with you know the rebel mode well
what I did here is I started an
operating system process right a process
with a process ID and node I exposed
this process object so there's a process
object that has a few methods a lot of
methods actually and this process object
is basically the interface between your
node environment and the operating
system environment so if you need to
read anything from the operating system
or if you need to write anything to the
operating system then you use this
process object so it's the interface so
this interface for example exposes the
environment variables so all the
environment variables that you have in
your system just with process the in
this give you access to everything
invite in the environment that you have
which is a cool way to customize your
notes session so you just put something
in the environment hopefully I don't
have any passwords in here you put
something in the environment and you can
just access it in node right including
things like you know including
the built-in environment variables so so
so the built-in environment variables
are special environment variables that
if you set them if you set them then you
you get to change the behavior of note
however before I talk about that let me
show you how to control the environment
is this is this is important so let's
say no - P and let's let's print process
the end the user user is a standard
environment variable right so this is
the user that I'm using if you want to
change that all you need to do is just
specify a different user right and no it
will just use a new value that you put
in here instead of you know that's set
in value because I changed the
environment variable before executing
node and of course I can do export or
step on Windows to change it for to
change it forever you cannot change
there's a very good question from Amith
you cannot change the environment
variable through process the end it's
not it's read-only things although you
can actually change it so you can do you
know equal tests but this will not
change the environment variable here
okay so I think if you do that right and
try to echo a dollar sign user after
that it did not change it so node will
not tell you that oh you can't change it
it's not really immutable but you get a
copy you don't you get a copy of the
object all right so let's keep going
if you have so if you want to change
some kind of behavior I'd like to point
your attention to a few of these
environment variables one one one handy
in particular is note debug so if you do
if you use a library like for example
HTTP and you'd like node to debug more
information about what it's doing in
HTTP you can you can do something like
this so you can note debug I think you
just do HTTP and then run your node
command
and this will tell node to debug more
information when it uses the HTTP
library so very handy when you start
running into problems you can change its
a path so this is another important one
that we're gonna talk about we're gonna
actually talk about that next it is how
to control how no discover modules so
let's go ahead and jump into the more
serious mode which is to run node in to
run a script so I'm gonna create a
directory so node I'll just do 0 6 19
and I'm gonna go into this directory not
this one and I'll just run vs code on
this directory to start exploring things
and I'll actually let me just do
everything in vs code so let's see I'll
have the terminal in here yes good and
make it bigger so if you have vs code
you can use the terminal built in
terminal otherwise you can still use the
other terminal so I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna create a file in here and call
this file index dot JSP things in index
Tijs so don't worry about yes lint for
now so in here you can do anything that
we just did so you can do math dot
random right and now math at random and
you can execute this file however it
will not output anything because it just
executed executed a value so this is not
rebel node so if we execute node index
that yes it will do nothing output
nothing because we're not a rebel mode
now we're in script execution mode which
means if you want to output something to
the operating system the operating
system that's running the process then
you have to use the interface to the
operating system for example you can do
process so process the STD out don't
worry about the syntax dot right and in
here you would do math dot random and it
will probably not work because right
expects a string so let's try that I
think it will not work
yep
did not work because right here expects
a string so what do you do well you can
change this to two string so in here
what I did is JavaScript this is a
JavaScript expression I just made it
interesting let's make sure this is
working
yep this works so this is a JavaScript
expression right and I fed it to a node
API so this is a node API process the
STD I'll write is a node API now of
course this is very raw a you know lower
level because you have the console
object the console object is also
supported so I can do math dot random
through the console object and that is
going to output it as well and then it's
a lot easier I didn't have to cast it
into a string I did not have to put a
new line after the output it actually
colored it differently so console.log is
another node API and actually if you go
find the source code to a console dot
log for node you'll find that it uses
process the STD out there right so there
are many many ways to do things there
are lower-level api's and higher level
API what if you console dot log an
object what if we console the log
process for example process is an object
what's gonna happen well it's gonna it's
gonna print a huge this is the default
behavior for console to log it will
print a huge object and go through all
the nesting so everything that you can
do on not just the first level
properties for process but everything in
it including arrays and all the
environment variables right so this is
not a very handy output what what do you
do to make it handy well you can use
other higher-level api's for example the
dirt one might be a little bit better
let's actually the third one is exactly
the same but the dirt one accepts depth
I think or like it accepts an object and
in here you can say depth is zero I
think so let's try that yeah so it gave
me only the first level so without any
nesting what is the first level of
properties that you have on
process object so this is a cool trick
where you can start exploring so it did
not expand the big things that you have
in process so this is me executing a
script right so we're gonna talk about
how node does this magic how does it
execute a script can you turn on the
buggin for all libraries using no debug
I don't think so I think you can I have
a comma separated list so you can do
like FS and paths but usually you want
to debug one library because if you turn
on everything there will be thousands
and thousands of debugging lines and
it's not really helpful alright so I am
going to ask you a question and let's
pretend that we are in an interview and
I'm interviewing you for an old position
so I'm gonna ask you an interview
question I am gonna so you know the
about the you know function X right and
function X and we're gonna call it and
function X is gonna console.log
arguments so arguments is a special
keyword that present everything that you
pass to X as an argument right so let's
pass X three arguments so one seven and
nine so what is arguments in this case
if I execute this code it will be one
seven and nine now you'll notice that
arguments looks like an object not an
array that's because arrays in
JavaScript are just objects they're just
special objects where the properties are
numeric just like that so it is this is
an array all right cool so you
understand that right now my question is
what is gonna happen if I just
console.log arguments without any
function what is the output in this case
so that's your first interview question
tell me what is the output in this case
and if your answer is going to be
undefined you're gonna be surprised
arguments in this case is another array
there is an array here with how many
arguments with five exact arguments
so what are these five arguments and why
is arguments working here arguments is
something that you get in a function
right why is it working top level not
what we're not in a function and what
are these five arguments that you get
this is core knowledge in node so the
reason arguments worked is because node
has this concept of wrapping wrapping
modules right so this is what it does it
wraps your code in a function so you get
this if e by default you everything you
do in node gets this if e if he is
immediately invoked function expression
immediately invoked function expression
so you get this if e by default no just
does this wrapping automatically and it
also does other stuffs for example it
returns something from your from your
file we're gonna talk about that but
just in general I want you to know that
you get this if e by default this is why
arguments work so kind of like this no
it has this Fe and it executed it
immediately that's what you get and the
arguments that you get are mod one of
them is module one of them is exports
one of them is a file name and learning
so let's actually take a look at them
real quick I think I'm missing one yeah
so require is the first one what exports
is the first one yeah exports is the
first one I think and then you get
required and then you get module exports
is the first one then acquire then
module you can actually take a look at
them if you just do
if you require module you can take a
look at the wrapper require module dot
wrapper you see that require module dot
wrapper
require module dot wrapper so this is
exactly what you get exports require
module filename and earning this is the
actual wrapper that you know uses it's
exactly that all right cool
so here's the thing if you if you have
two files right so we're gonna have
another file in here index 1 and index 2
index 1 and index 2 GS and I'm just
gonna split them split down alright so
you've got index 1 and index 2 right
what I want you to know is that every
function every file that you initialize
gets this magic Fe right so if I if I
constant log exports in here
right experts is something that you get
from the arguments right and I
console.log it in here these exports are
different right they're not the exact
same object although if you execute them
they're exactly the same it's an empty
object right but this empty object Oh
index to save this empty object that you
get in index to analytics 1 these are
different objects they're not exactly
the same object why because they're
coming from an argument that no passes
to your iffy function so that's
important so all of them are different
right exports require module file name
and their name file name is of course
the name of the file that you're
executing and their name is the name of
the directory where your file is that
you're executing so you need to learn
about exports and and acquired these are
two basic things in in node this is the
node you know module dependency system
so next we're gonna talk about these two
in rebel mode you don't have arguments
because you're not really executing a
file this is when you execute a file
this is how node manages files and
modules
how is console.log working when you run
node file name as console.log is
available only in browser yes console
lock is available in node so node tries
to mirror the browser's API right so
when it comes to input and output not
so there's no time you can't do document
you can't in here you can't say oh look
anywhere really you can't say document
document dot get element by ID that is
not going to work why because you don't
have Dom so this will tell you undefined
some kind of error document is not
defined right so it's not exactly the
browser however node opted to implement
things like console like set timeout and
many and a few other things that exist
in a browser environment but they're not
JavaScript right so these api's are
built in node and their implementation
is different than the implementation of
the browser so and v8 has nothing to do
with them v8 is just gonna organize the
execution of functions and callbacks but
these these api's are not-- cool that's
why so if you go grab the source code of
node you're gonna find the console
object and a lot function in the node
source code right not in v8 and not for
any browsers okay cool no questions keep
them coming
so we're look we're learning about this
iffy function if he wrapping function
right cool so what is exports exports is
an object that you can change so exports
is a mutable object so we can say
exports dot answer is 42 and you can put
any number of properties on exports and
when we execute this file exports is
gonna be whatever you define it so it's
just a special object that is available
globally for you it's also an alias to
module duck exports so if I do module
the exports the another answer then I am
changing the exact same property so you
see how I changed it here and I change
it it bear so exports is just an alias
to module the exports cool and here's
the thing node when it manages a file it
returned
module exports so whatever you put on
exports that would be the return value
of the index file the index module now
why is this handy because another file
might require your module so let's call
this module one this index is your
module right and you want index two to
use your module to use index what you do
is you require you just use require and
you pass in a string and you say index
two is gonna require index one
Dodge's just like that index two is
gonna require in this one so note what's
gonna happen and in here I'm not gonna
console.log I'm just gonna console.log
let's console.log in index dot yes right
let's pass a lot of an index digest so
just by requiring index if I execute
index two what can happen is note is
going to look at this find require and
it will require this file so it will
execute this file so I'm gonna get the
console log message although I'm
executing index two so that's that's the
story of require but here's how it's
helpful it's helpful because require
gives you access to whatever this module
the export things is returning so
whatever you put in module the exports
you get it in here so in here you get an
object index I'm just gonna call it
index and I'm just gonna log index so
guess what index is going to be index
after index that in in index digest this
here you get the exported module so this
is module two exports so whatever you
put on module the exports or its alias
exports you get it out when you require
a file so require is dependencies module
dependencies it's similar to import and
export in JavaScript in fact you can
also use import and export and I'm going
to show you how that because this is new
this is new in node you get to use
exports and imports all so any questions
about
and this exports business because that
is that is core knowledge all all the
packages out there that are written for
note they use this syntax they use
exports and require all right cool so
I'm going to clean all this and just
console.log hello and in here
I am going to require index that yes and
I'm gonna execute the file that's
requiring so this will output hello
right cool here is your second interview
question what's gonna happen if I do
that if I require index three times
what's gonna happen so go ahead and try
and answer this will output hello one
time what why the output hello one time
and not three times right and the reason
is note has this required function in
node has some magic caching it doesn't
evaluate the file every time you require
it it evaluated once and then the second
time it reads it from the cache so this
is why in a in an application say to
react application or an angular
application you require react all over
the place you require angular all over
the place multiple files are gonna
require react or angular or view and
only the first require is gonna actually
do the work the second require will just
read it from the cache so well another
interview question is what if I do want
this file to console.log hello every
time I require it and the answer is you
really can't you require you get cash
that's just that's just the reality
however you can delay what you execute
in the file by making it return a
function
so remember module to export right
module the export is our API so instead
of having the
console.log directly you can't have it
export a closure you can have an export
a function closure and you execute that
function every time you want it so if I
make module de exports into a function
and I'm gonna use error function in here
but you can just use a regular function
and I make this function console.log
hello instead of that now I have delayed
execution now every time I require index
dot yes
what do I get every time I require index
suggest I get back a function it does
not have any code it will just cache the
function reference and I can just
execute this function that I get back
from index that yes so if I do that and
I execute this I get hello three times
so we use this trick a lot in node we
make Lee module exports a function and
we execute the code in that function so
it's a little bit of delayed execution
what gets cached is the function itself
not the function execution cool alright
so there are many cases where you get me
you want to execute something in a file
multiple times right so this is how you
do it you always execute a function in
fact if you need the file to have
multiple capabilities what you do is you
make it export an object and in the
object you have your capabilities you do
like function one function to function
three right so this is another way to
export API so how would you do that
how would you invoke function one now
what you get back is an object right
it's not a function it's an object and
because it's an object it's an object
that has F one I can do dot F one right
dot F one because it's an object and
execute F one right and this will work
as well so whatever you put in here this
require is just gonna use it right so
and you can put anything right you can
put primitive values you can put arrays
objects or you can have like a proxy
anything that is supported by the
language you can use it as the exports
value in your
and you get to use it exactly as we
define it right whatever you have we
have an object has an f1 property so
I'll just cut like get the f1 property
and then because the f1 property itself
is a function I can execute f1 right so
there's nothing magic in here it's just
JavaScript mixed with the API that no
gives you to require functions now this
is a little bit different than the
import-export syntax that is that is
native to the JavaScript language right
this module require business is nodes
way to do module dependency and it
existed since day one in node so like
ten years before JavaScript decided to
have a module dependency as well now the
problem is you have two systems one has
been used for ten years and the
brand-new one that everybody is gonna
start using because it works in browsers
as well
so what do you do well here's what you
do you really understand require module
to export as to understand it really
good because you're gonna have to deal
with packages that are written in this
sentence for at least five to ten years
into the future if you're working in
node project but in your own parting a
node project today I would recommend
that you use the import/export syntax
not the required syntax now they have
different implementation and I'm gonna
tell you about that in just a little bit
just so that you aware but I'm going to
show you the import-export n tax first
so let's go ahead and do that so let's
do this exact same example but instead
of working with require let's do it with
with important export right so here's
the thing if you have node twelve right
if you have node twelve you can use
import and export out of the box it's
actually supported but remember that
it's not LTS so no twelve is not
Althea's yet
what's the MV m LS system no twelve
so nvm use system
MVM LS remote while we're talking about
it I'm just gonna get the latest and
greatest node which is V 1214 and I'll
use that so MDM install this thing and
this will install the latest so what do
you do here is you create a package that
JSON file to start managing your
dependencies right let's actually name
this m1 and m2 because they're kind of
different so m1 and m2 and I'm just
gonna call em two in here m1 m1 that is
N 1 and n 2 so exact same example I just
named them in m1 and m2 instead of what
I had before all right and and you can
run them with the latest node so this
syntax is not going anywhere so although
we have node V 12 now we can still run
m2 and we get the exact same behavior so
export and require is exactly the same
but what I'm to do is I'm gonna change
this into important export but to do
that I need the package JSON file
so what is a package that JSON file a
package that JSON file is the file that
you can use to manage meta information
about your node projects so every node
package out there has a package that
JSON file to tell you its name its
version its get repository how to run
things in it so you create a package
that JSON file with the NPM command
so what NPM is the node package manager
and we're going to talk about it in the
next hour after the break but for now
the first step is to use the NPM init
command to create a package dot JSON
file that we can use to control things
in nodes so @p a minute and this will
ask you a few questions us or it can
detect if you do - Y which is for yes it
says just try to detect whatever you can
detect from this this object and just
give me a package JSON file so this will
create a package of the JSON file using
the name of the directory using a
default version it will try to find if
you have git installed it will
to find the get remote that you have it
just detects a few things so in package
that Jason you get to specify
information about your package so for
example if you put your name on the
package so that when you push it people
know if you want to have keywords so
people can find your package in the
search you can use this meta information
so there is a new by the way the only
two required properties in package that
jason are just name and version these
are the only required everything else is
optional so the new the new property
that you can use here on package that
jason is the type property and if you
specify your type as module instead of
commonjs
so the other one I think is common
common jazz which is the name that is
that we use for you know the require
exports thing but if you specify your
type as module then node will switch
gears and just assume that you're just
gonna use your ECMO script modules all
over the place so there's no require and
exports in fact I think if we try to
execute it now it will not execute it
will not be happy it will say well I
actually executed that does not work oh
we need a flag so we need the
experimental modules there you go see
so this flag is actually gonna go away
when node goes into LTL I'm not sure
when they're gonna remove it but they
will remove it but this is this is how
node is gonna behave when it switches to
the ECMO script the ASM module loader
see this is now the ESM module loader so
it tells you I don't know require
because I'm assuming that you are in um
in a neck massager
right you're not in a node module you're
an ECMO script module which means you
cannot use exports you cannot use
require so what can you use you use
export default and in here you pass in
the object that you'd like to export so
it's kind of similar to what you did but
in here where we have a little bit of
different syntax export default so
instead of module de exports you do
export default
and instead of require what you do is
you import you use the import keyword so
import m1 from dot slash m1 dot yes well
import m1 from the slash in Monda yes
and now you get to do m1 dot f1 and
execute that three times so you'll see a
little bit of different syntax but it's
basically the same module dependency so
this works right you get a warning that
it is experimental but it's really just
it works fine they're just making sure
that the API is stable so it is the
exact same thing except there's no
require there's no module the expert
cool now we have a big question
what is a module so that is an important
question what is a module so I'm gonna
give you the short answer and I'll give
you the long answer after the break
so the short answer is a module is just
a file it's just a bunch of code lines
of code in a file but it can also be
multiple files right and we get to we
now we need to understand what happens
when you require or import a module I'll
just I'll just use import in here what's
gonna happen when you import not a local
file so in here what we imported is a
local file right and one what happens if
you import say HTTP from HTTP what
happens if you do that because this is
not local because there is no even this
this dot slash means a file on the same
level trying to file a find a file on
the same level or a folder on the same
level so if you don't have duck slash or
dot dot slash that means go find this in
a special somewhere and this special
somewhere is what we're going to talk
about next is called the node modules
directory and I want to tell you how
node modules tie in to NPM and other
package managers and how things work
magically now HTTP is a built in module
so it doesn't really go and look for it
in the node modules directory it just
take it from the built-in core the
comes installed out-of-the-box with
known but if you do import from Express
for example which is a package that you
can use to replace hdtb then you need to
have Express installed this is not a
third-party package they said this is
not a built-in package it's a
third-party package so you have to
install it you have to let NPM install
this before you can use it so we'll do
that right after the break so can we
have a library of components and import
it as a module for another project
definitely the answer is big yes that's
how node works in fact when we import
HTTP what we're importing is a small
library of things that we can use and
you can explore this right away by
console logging HTTP so let's take a
look at what we get when we import HTTP
and in here we're just gonna execute m1
format from now on m1 and you get a
library a little library object with a
few methods so there is status codes for
example all the HTTP status codes are
here so if you want to look them up all
you need to do is HTTP status codes you
get a few important methods and and
objects and classes in here and the most
important one is create server so HTTP
that create server creates an HTTP
server that's what we're gonna use next
if you have node 10 this is not going to
work what we're doing here import HDB is
not going to work so you have two
options either upgrade to node 12 and
use that or you can use the ESM package
and this is how you do it you add cam
installed ESM and this will download ESM
from the internet and place it under a
node modules folder so we're going to
talk about that in just a little bit a
place ESM under a node modules folder
you see that and what you what you need
to do to run things with the sm is
instead of experimental modules you do -
or yes em - are yes i'm so on more time
- re sm so this will work
on node ten and eight and everything is
just a shim around experimental module
so you don't have you don't need no
twelve and it is it works actually
really good so that's our ESM so two new
things just happen we use the - our flag
what is - our so - our is you require a
module before you execute your code so
that's our is kind of like a wrapper
that you can inject a module into your
system before node executes your actual
module which is m1 degeus so that that's
that's our and ESM is just a package
that we downloaded so we can now import
ESM from node modules so before we talk
about HTTP I wanna I want to talk about
node modules right so if you import
let's say you want to import from like
or just import and you pass in something
you import something right what happens
here is when you put something
what node looks at something here
there's something string and it figures
out that this is not a built-in library
right it's not part of the built-in
library it's also not a local file
because you know it doesn't start with
dot slash or dot dot slash so if it's
start with dot slash or dot dot slash
that means it's a local file go find it
locally where we're importing but
because it does not start with dot or
dot dot slash that means it's not a
local file so know by default will tell
you that I don't know what something is
cannot find module something because it
looks under node modules so it tries to
find something dot yes under node
modules so if we go to your node modules
and we put something dot yes and we and
we do something we do and we put
anything here in digest so this is just
a test so what I did is I put something
just under node modules and guess what
now
I am importing something and there is
something that is under node modules it
will find it so there's no magic here it
just looks for things under node modules
that's that's what node does right and
you can actually make this into a folder
instead of a file so you can have a
folder called something under node
modules you can make a folder and name
it something and put your code under
this folder and by default node looks
for index dot yes under the folder so
just a test here from a folder right and
you and if you import something here
right you I can import the folder and it
will look for the index that you has
file under that folder and that's
exactly how note resolved your external
dependencies so if we npm install lodash
for example if we npm install lo - hello
- is a javascript library that you can
use it has a lot of cool utility
functions that you can use in in our
missing JavaScript you can use them
so what MPM does is it just places let's
refresh this it places lo - just like I
did for something it places lo - under
your nose modules directory that's what
IPM does it has nothing to do with
import and export it just download slow
- and put it under the node modules
folder in your project then here we can
import lo - because it is no module it
is under node modules then it is
something that I can just import and
import directly means just execute so
I'm not really interested in anything
that the library returns like whatever
the library exports right but if you
want to not use whatever the library
exports and you have to give it a name
usually lo - we do import underscore
from lo - and now we get to do use the
lodash functions for example we can sum
in the range so this is one two three
and it will summon array of course we
need to console.log that so you want to
put it in a console log m1 and it is not
working is it at all
get it put it in a race it doesn't some
an argument it will summon irate okay
cool so this is how we use external
libraries we use NPM to download them
and place them under the node modules
folder then we use node package
management to import them into the
project and use their API in in the
project that's how that's the story of
node packages and how to use them in
general how do I make my library
available for people to use it as
imports in their project very good
question
what if our something that yes is turn
turns out to be handy and we want to
make it available for other people to
use it what we do is we publish it under
NPM now or we publish it under a
repository in general right but if I
want to publish my something that you
ask all I need to do is I need to help
make it have a package.json and then I
can just NPM pop lish this this thing
NPM publish now to publish NPM you have
to have an account with NPM and NPM GS
comm right and it has to be a valid
package and you have to have the right
to push through this package if it's a
new package if NPM doesn't have a
package named something already so the
name is unique then it will allow you to
push it but if you're trying to push
through a package that exists you need
to have rights to it so they need to add
you as a contributor to that package and
of course you can publish to github
directly github in fact if we look for
lodash in here
github low - low - right you can
actually install low - directly from
github or let's let's let's talk about
Express so I'm gonna I'm gonna do that
for you next Express not here Express
Express is a framework a web framework
that you can use to replace STD so we're
I'm gonna install Express from github
directly so the minute you push
something to github it's
available for people to use it with
their node projects so let's use let's
MPM Express from github so when I do in
here NPM install Express just like that
that will install it from the NPM
registry it will not install it from
anywhere else because I'm doing NPM
install the default is the NPM registry
but if I use this expression here which
is you know just Express the GS /
Express instead of Express NPM will
detect that you mean go get express from
github by default this expression means
oh this looks like you know older slash
repository so it must be from github so
what it what exactly does it do it will
get the exact latest commits the one
that happens 25 days ago so it will give
you the latest and greatest of Express
so it's not the published package so the
final published package was in NPM if
you go to NV MGS comm and you look for
Express this has expressed this is this
is the package that you get if you just
install it directly from Express and the
final package was 417 one and it is 25
days ago so it looks like they match but
if someone pushed something to get to
Express today and then you do did NPM
install Express / Express you get the
exact same commits that happened today
not the actual final published package
but this is how easy for you to get
something from github so if you push
your package to github you can get it
github also has a package registry that
they're working on so you can install
things from github directly as well but
the package has to exist exist somewhere
you have to publish it somewhere right
all right cool good questions keep them
coming
how does the repository validate the
authors right to upload very good
question so you'll have to have some
kind of authentication and by default it
asks you for to login so there is you
create an account with NPM j/s and you
login with an email
and password so if you do npm publish
you will ask you for you log in it you
log in and password but you can also use
SSH keys if you want to say you know
just like you push to a github
repository and just like how github
validate that you have commit access to
that repository using a succession
education but you do need to
authenticate somehow and after you
authenticate because they know your
identity they're gonna do the
authorization they're gonna validate in
their system does this person have the
right to push to this repository or to
this package alright great questions
keep them coming so we were talking
about import and export so I think that
is that is basically all the time we
have to talk about node modules and
import and export because we need to
explore other things in in the node
ecosystem so if you have any questions
about what we did so far before we move
on about all the import and export stuff
the require the the ACMA script modules
the node modules directory package jason
and how these things work together
definitely now is the time to ask them
but otherwise we're gonna explore the
HTTP package so we're gonna create
certain fact I'm gonna call it server
Dodge's I'm gonna create a server here
so I'll delete everything I'll just keep
server degeus and I don't really need
any of those things so I'm gonna show
you how to get rid of them and then just
delete everything and just keep oh man
we have a lot of stuff that came from
Express but I'll show you how to clean
this up so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna create a server not here sorry in
here we're gonna create server JS file
and we're gonna execute the server
digest file so in here we're gonna pass
a log hello node and we're gonna execute
so what are we executing here is just oh
man no it's zero sink yeah all right I'm
gonna just execute no - re SM and server
digest
we're gonna actually create a web server
in here and we're gonna do it first
natively with node and then we'll do it
with Express all right so are we gonna
talk can modules be installed globally
yes so if you want to install a module
globally all you need to do is npm
install dash G so that G flag means
install this module globally for example
I want to have a module to create a
react project or create react app create
react tab is a candidate for something
that you want to have globally because
it just creates a react app for you it's
not really part of a dependency like
lodash or Express you don't depend on it
you just use it to create something
another module that is a good candidate
for a global is es lint you won't have
es lens in all your node projects so
maybe just manage it globally although
it is probably a better idea to manage
things locally even for even es lint
because you want to make sure that the
whole team uses the exact same version
and they don't depend on a global
dependency so I would avoid global
dependencies unless you know it's a
thing that you use globally for
everything it's a command basically
unless it's a command that gives you
about a binary executable command
just use local dependencies so let me
mention a few more things about packaged
on Jason we're limited on time but I'll
talk a little bit more about it so one
thing that you can do is use scripts so
probably the most important part of
package that Jason for me in a big
project is the user scripts in fact if
we go I'm gonna show you a sneak peek
into the package that Jason for the J's
complete project so let's take a look at
the package that JSON this is the Jas
complete calm this is packaged in JSON
for J's complete that form and you'll
see that I have so many things under the
scripts directory see that all of these
are a tasks that we use to run things
J's complete some of them are
development tasks so things that we do
for development and some of them are
production tasks the things that we do
for production and these are different
so
any any person who uses who works on the
J's complete project they know exactly
how to start a dev process they know
exactly how to bundle things for dev
they know exactly how to send all the
gist drops emails or update all the
email templates or log things in
production so these texts these tasks
are unified let me know we always have
to do it this way so how do we do that
in in our project so let's let's create
a task so for example instead of always
doing node - our ESM server yes right
and if you if you bring someone new to
the team you have to tell them oh you
have to use - or ESM in our project
instead of doing that you can have a
start script you can say you know what
we're gonna put this in a start script
so the start script is node - art ESM
server yes this is how you start our
system and now it's a global knowledge
because all I need to do is NPM start
because I can run the script directly
NPM start I don't have and if you bring
someone new to that table they know they
they know to look for NPM start right
because you know it's a it's a global
language there's what can I do for this
project well you can start it and boom
hello node it is running the - Ari sm
server so you will have a lot more in
here for example what do we do to test
things right maybe are we using mocha
are we using just where where do we look
up the tests so maybe that will be like
oh just just under you know star star
type or whatever things that you do and
now you can do NPM test and it will run
just now I don't have just installed so
this will tell me where what is just I
don't know just but you get the idea
so these are special commands that you
can do with just NPM start and NPM test
but they're equivalent to doing NPM run
start so NPM start is equivalent to
doing NPM run start it's just a special
one that has a shortcut but in general
if you do something like let's say I
want to do it dev start not
not just start or prod how do you start
for production for example how do you
start things for a production well in
production I'm gonna use the I'm gonna
use node in the equal production for
example and then do not know - re SM
server that yes right so I slightly
different to run things in production
then in development right so you have a
different tasks for production run and
if you want to run this task then you
have to use npm run prod start because
it doesn't have a shortcut so at 10 p.m.
run prod script in fact these things are
called run scripts because he uses in
with npm run cool you can also use yard
so if you're using the yarn yarn is
gonna run into yarn will funny so you
don't need to do yarn run so it's a
little bit different in how the package
manager is using so since I mentioned
npx
I want to quickly talk about MPX so MPX
is NPM x-cubed right so let's say you
wanna NPM install - G create react app
create yak tab is just an example so
don't have worry about it in fact I'm
gonna use react so so react was just
another one that I use and if you if you
have we actually install then you can do
react new I think project this is the
command that you get react full react
react full so you get a binary react
full new project and it will create a
reacts full project for you so this is
the command that you can use but this
will install reacts full globally and
then use it right so a month from now if
I come back to the project and I do
another react full command
react full new project to then it will
install then I will use the exact same
reaction package that I installed a
month ago if I want to get the latest
and greatest every time I use the react
Ville command instead of NPM install
global I can just use npx react ville
and then invoke the
and px react for new project and what
this command is going to do it will
install a temporary copy of react ville
so it will download the temp copy of
react ville use it and then delete it so
I don't have a local copy anymore every
time I want to use the react Ville
project I can just download it with MPX
in one command and it will download the
latest and greatest and then use it use
the command that comes with it because
the command matches the the package name
cool so this is MPX to install something
globally and download it but it's also
available if you if you're in your
project if you have something that you
need to execute for example let's say
that we installed - - - - dev so I'm
gonna install - G this is another thing
that we need to talk about and I'm gonna
install the eslint right es lint so - D
means development dependency it means we
don't really need it in production this
is just in development so if I do - D it
will it will put it not under
dependencies but rather under dev
dependencies you see that so when you
run things in production if you have
this production flag if you have note n
equal production and you run things with
the production flag it will not install
the dev dependencies right it will just
ignore them
it will only install the local
dependencies because the eslint is not
something that you want to have in
production yes light is a good quality
check that will check things while you
develop developing them but here's the
thing because just because we npm
install the eslint doesn't mean that we
get to execute the es link command there
is no es linked command where is the es
link command the es link command is deep
under the node modules folder under dot
bin so you can you can execute it from
node modules been yes lint and and this
will execute the node the es link
command fine so it's it's not under it's
under node modules right because NPM
just install things under the node
modules folder
so if you want to execute it without
figuring out where it is or you know how
to execute it you can't just use the MPX
command here as well
and PXE eslint and this will try to find
it under the node modules folder for you
so MPX is a handy tool to do that
that comes with with NPM of course if
you have yarn you can just do the same
thing with the arm so you're in just one
command and it will you do that it will
find the package for you
now if you put things in in a in a
script so if here we do check for
example and we do es Linde NPM is also
smart enough to figure out that so check
in here to figure out where to look for
es wins so we can just NPM check I mean
run Jack right and it will also work as
well so it will execute the ps1 command
all right so this is dependencies dev
dependencies and scripts very important
things in package that Jason if I delete
a dependency from package that Jason
would it eliminate it from the project
very good question in fact let's go
ahead and delete lo - right so if we
delete lo - because we not we're not
gonna use it it does not eliminate it
from and by default and still under node
modules so the package that JSON file is
just a documentation of what
dependencies were installed but lo - is
still under the node modules folder
right so I will it go away if I do NPM
install so if you do NPM install it
reads everything that you have in
package that JSON and it gives you all
the missing dependencies right but it
does not remove the you know the
dependencies that you do not depend on
anymore so this is just the NPM be I
think yarn behavior is different but
here's the thing you should not really
do it this way if you want to kill the
dependency you should do NPM uninstall
lodash NPM uninstall lo - so this will
remove it from the node modules and it
will remove
from packaged that Jason so my advice is
do not touch dependencies and dev
dependencies manually in your package to
Jason you can only change the meta
information you can add scripts manually
that's fine it's just dependencies and
dev dependencies make them go through
the NPM command itself right this is
just the advice unless you want to
change the this weird character here the
caret character which means give me
anything that is compatible with three
three so basically so three three would
be fine here three four would be fine
but not four so it says like give me
everything that is compatible with three
so it might give you minor version as
well so if you want to change this and
say you know what I want this dependency
to be exact
do not when you update your package
always use the exact same dependency and
not give me any a new version or give me
just the patch so there are like special
meanings for all these some things but
this is a bit advanced these you can
change them if you want to you can also
just say star in here which means give
me the latest and greatest even if it
was es m5 I don't care just give me the
latest so a major minor we call this you
know that the semver string and this is
the semper version here so major minor
and patch so you have to learn about sin
Verte and how how to manage those
alright so we'll go ahead and talk about
a HTTP next so this is how you create a
node web server you import HTTP from
HTTP and then you do HTTP dot create
server so this API is from note STP duck
crate server and it's gonna teach us a
few things about about node so what you
get back from here depends on the API so
you can name it anything right in here
you can name it anything so you don't
have to stick with the API this this
name here has to be create server
because that's the function the API
exposes but here we can name it anything
usually I name
this server right so this is the server
and you make server listen on some kind
of port so we make it listen on port
3000 for example so this is the API to
create a web server now if you npm start
because that's the script that we put
the npm start you'll notice that node
did not exit the process did not exit
right I did not go back to the terminal
command and this is because of the
listen so if I kill the listen and read
this again it will create a server and
then it will exit I am back to the
terminal
right it did not it did not continue
running so it is important for you to
understand that node will only continue
running if it has a reason to continue
to run right if it has a reason to
continue to run and that reason is do we
have any asynchronous calls that are
listening do we have any handlers for
example I can have a set timeout set
timeout is a timer right that we can run
say after five seconds so it gives in
here in milliseconds and let's just do
nothing right set timeout after five
seconds just for just to keep node busy
for five seconds so because there is a
reason for node to stick around for five
seconds when we run this code node will
not exit for five seconds and then after
the five seconds it will have no reason
to stay running and it will just exit
right so that's extremely important note
processes will exit if they don't have a
reason to stay running so for example if
in here if we do server that listen
which is a reason for node to stay
running forever right because it's
listening right it's listening forever
so it's a reason for it to start just to
stick around forever but if this listen
function deep internally through an
error if there's an error then that
error is gonna make the process crash
and exit because there's no reason for
note to stick around there's an error so
that process the state of that listening
server is
so Note will crash from exit so what
does that mean for you in production
that means is note by itself the note
command by itself is not enough in
production because if you're just
running a single node process in
production that process might crash and
exit at any point so you'll have to
monitor this process and you'll have to
have a cluster of processes and maybe
even a cluster of servers if you need to
so that if one process crashes and exits
another process is automatically started
because it is normal for a node process
to crash and exit and if it has no
reason to stay around it will not stay
around alright now this server is
listening when we emit you will not exit
unless there is a crash and error right
it will not exit but it is doing nothing
right it's just listening there is no
handler for what to do when an HTTP
connection comes in so this is an HTTP
server right so there is no information
about what to do when an HTTP connection
comes in so right now it will probably
say undefined if we try to access
anything if we go to localhost localhost
and we go to port 3000 right it will
probably not do anything waiting for
localhost and it will timeout because
there is no instruction but here's the
thing the HTTP server received the
request it just did not handle the
request and the way it does this is
through the event the events concept so
everything is handled with events so
when when I hit that localhost port 3000
in the browser I the the HTTP in the
server object is going to emit an event
that says oh I received a connection
what should I do with it so to handle
the connection I just handle the event I
do something like server dot on and I
specify the event that I'm interested in
which is a request for Connect I don't
know I don't know what it is I think
it's request we'll see and in here you
get
what you do stuff in here so what do you
want to do on request now if you don't
know what the event is you can so so
here's the thing if if if you're using a
library like typescript for example
which I recommend that you check out
then you'll immediately get all the
discoverability of everything because
server is a typed object and we know all
the events on it we know all the stuff
in it but if you don't if you don't have
this signature around then just look at
the documentation know the API
documentation czar really really good so
you just go to the node API and you look
for HTTP and you look for the on the on
socket that on connect you look for
connect there's no there's a lot of in
here but I think what we're looking for
is request right so you'll find that the
request event here right and you can
feel like find examples what is happen
this is the event request right and
here's what you get when you handle the
event request you get a request object
and the response object right and this
is exactly what we're gonna do here
we're gonna get a request object and the
response object this is when I handle
the request so in here you can do
anything to new computations you can go
ask the database for information
whatever you need to do this function
here which we call the callback function
but it's really more like a handler
function in this case is going to be
invoked every time there is a request
every time I put on localhost port 3000
and hit enter that's a request right so
let's console.log a request and let's
response send something so hello
HTTP so this is how you do it response
that's the dot right not send response
dot right hello HTTP and then response
the end
now don't worry about the API yet this
this will eventually learn because these
things the response object here is a
stream
we need to stream information this is
why we needed to do that in for the HTTP
protocol to say oh I'm done but I want
to show you that response that right now
we need to restart this process every
time you change something in a node
project you have to restart node know
does not have the development mode
out-of-the-box
so you have to restart it and now if I
go to localhost port 3000 I will see
hello HTTP so the message that I wrote
Suresh túcume and note how I did all of
this without any libraries I'm not using
Express I installed Express but I'm not
using it I'm just using the built-in
HTTP library now if you look at the
terminal for the thing that we just did
you'll notice that we have two requests
not just one request although i refresh
the browser just once I ask for that
page just once so for some reason this
handler is being called twice
every time we request so why well you
need to discover why so to discover why
maybe you can print information about
the request why am I doing this request
and I know that there is a request that
URL that you can use to figure out what
URL is being requested so now if we go
back and write and we have to restart
the server remember we have to restart
the server if we go back and refresh the
browser once and go back to see what
requests are being made here Oh check it
out so we're requesting that and we're
requesting the fav icon so the browser
is requesting the Fath icon by default
that's chrome just trying to find the
fab I come for that website so you have
to be aware of these things right that
you invoke the the request every time
there is a request from the browser and
the browser might do requests internally
for its own rendering write an apple an
iPhone might request the you know I'd
the Apple compressed icon for the tablet
and Apple compressed icon for the iPhone
right it will request the four things
actually so
you have to handle these right now how
do you handle right how do you say Oh
what should we do if the request is I
have I can request we should serve a
small image so you would need to come in
here and because of how limited this
library is you would need to come in
here and say something you know what if
the request that URL is to have icon
then do something different right you
would have to do something like this to
handle routes basically right maybe in
here you just want to respond response
not right nothing no I don't have a 5
icon else else right hello HTTP right so
now the 5 icon is not gonna get any
response where previously it got a
string response right so you'll have to
you have to have extra logic to deal
with routing basically because this is a
very raw HTTP package that has no no you
know rich API for dealing with routes or
dealing with files what if you want to
send the file to the browser right what
if I want to go to like you know give me
slash a dot PNG right if I want to get a
file an image I don't have a way to do
that I have to use a different library
to read the image from the operating
system and then write the binary
information that I get by reading the
image from the operating system into the
response stream in here so you have
limited capabilities but everything is
possible you can still do that you can
still read from the file system and and
and use the the the node response stream
to write to it but there is a better way
for dealing with this which is to
introduce a library specialized in that
kind of stuff all the basic needs for
you when you do a web server and that
library the most popular library is
Express so Express GS is well it's
really a framework around web servers
and every
all expect no developers to be familiar
with at least one web framework and
Express is just the popular one out
there so how to use Express that's what
we're gonna do next but before we do
that before we do that you might see
this handler written in a different way
instead of server the on request you
might see it in here directly as a
parameter to create server so this is
just a different syntax that you can use
without dealing with the dot on request
kind of thing so so actually hides the
dot on request
thing but I don't like this syntax
because I I need you to learn that this
is an event right and just like requests
there are other events there's connect
and disconnect and and many other events
and node packages are really burst into
this event nature so everything is an
event emitter we call server here an
event emitter so and you probably need
to learn your own event emitting skills
you have to be able to create an event
emitter and listen to and make it emit
events and listen to events because this
this this observer model in general we
call this the observer model you observe
something on something else and it
allows you to abstract your libraries so
that they don't depend on each other
they just send messages right and you
listen to messages and you act on four
messages
so this react fullness for the in the
observer model is really handy and this
is why it's all over the place in in in
note by default note has a limited
mechanism to to handle asynchronous
calls which is the callbacks and we
should probably talk about it a little
bit after after in the third hour I'm
going to talk a little bit about
callbacks and promises in general
because this is this is shifting from
node into modern JavaScript but in the
next five or ten minutes let's explore
Express so here's how you
a server would Express instead of
importing from HTTP we don't need an
HTTP you import Express from Express now
what do you get here when you import
Express you get a function so if you go
to the source code of Express you'll see
that the top-level import is a function
just like the function that we used when
we were testing you know the multiple
calls so if you want to use Express and
I'm just gonna comment out everything
here just to keep things just for
Express if you want to use Express you
because it's a function you just call it
and by calling a function what you get
back is a server instance so basically
just like you know the create server
function this Express function top-level
is equivalent to the create server
function all right so the listen is
actually exactly the same you just
listen on a port so 3000 just like that
you listen on a port 3000 just like you
did for the HTTP API but the route
handling is a little bit different right
the route handling is a little bit
different so instead of doing server dot
on you would do server got get and this
takes in an actual route get slash and
this will give you access to request and
response right so similar to dot on now
it's but it's now get so and you get
access to request and response just like
that but you also the response is a
wrapper around the raw stream response
that you get from node so in here you
can do other things you can do send or
send file if you want to this does not
exist in you know the regular actually
to be library so in here I can even send
an object if I want to send an object so
message is hello HTTP so you see how
hello express right because now we're in
Express so you have some and you don't
have to do response that end send is
gonna deal with this so it will abstract
some of these complexities in here and
also you get to be
very clean in the way you define your
routes because now I can also do fav
icon have icon ICO in fact I can do fab
icon star so if you call five I conduct
PNG I'm gonna respond to this route
there's like globbing going on here in
the routes so this and in here you would
send file you know the file icon
whatever the path does have icon so you
send the file directly in here right and
and express is gonna deal with reading
the file from the file system and
streaming it to the requester see how
this rich API is it's really still basic
but it gives you some capabilities to
just do features out of the box instead
of having to deal with this complexity
here but it is a wrapper around the raw
HTTP in fact what you get here this
listen method is exactly it's just
forwarded to the HTTP listen method
because express itself is just a wrapper
around the built in HTTP framework that
you get with note now we didn't really
talk about the difference between import
and export and require there is a slight
difference and and that you need to be
aware of which is import is statically
evaluated while required is dynamically
evaluated so what does that mean that
means import is always top level you
can't for example import something
inside another function you can't do
that you can't import something inside
the function that is invalid JavaScript
syntax why because import is statically
evaluated while you can totally require
something inside a function when if it's
note is why I require you can require
something inside a function because
require is dynamically evaluated and
then cached so that's a big difference
between import and export between import
and require now what if you want to
dynamically import something with echo
modules not with note if you make the
decision to use a coma script modules
and you want to lazily import something
basically you still have the option
because there is an import function as
well so ACMA script has an import
function which behaves kind of like
require in in in how it you can
dynamically call it and it gives you
back a promise so what this gives you
back is a promise now this is how import
is different than required which is
required although dynamically evaluated
it is synchronous so require is
synchronous while import is asynchronous
so we're gonna talk another five minute
break and come back top of the hour and
talk about synchronous and asynchronous
talk about callbacks and promises and
I'm well I'll go over some lore of lore
of the modern features in JavaScript
that you can use out of the box in nodes
and it will make your code for node
better and then we'll leave some some
some time for questions because I'm
pretty sure you're gonna have some all
right so no requires not really better
than import but it is just different
capabilities so if you want to have
something synchronously imported then
you can have a wrapper around this
import something it's just require
existed before Xmas script decided on
this import export syntax and its future
is probably that it's gonna exist in
node but it's not the way to go
but not for a few years we still need a
few years to stabilize this
import/export but I would say starting
node 14 no one is gonna remember I
require everyone is just gonna use
import and export and the reason is this
is going to work natively in the browser
so you can take the code as is and it
will work in the browser and the browser
is gonna do this the smartest thing to
try to fetch things in parallel from
locations so you would have to import
from an edge to actually be URL of
course you would have to import from
like github.com slash Express and and
things will work just like that and you
me too bundle things because right now
when we ship things to a browser we need
to bundle them we need to bundle them
into one file so that the browser can
understand them but in the very near
future and by near-future I mean it is
possible already but it's still
experimental but it's probably next year
or the year after that we will just ship
the same code to the browser and the
browser will work all right so what is
bundling really quick bundling is when
you take a front-end pack a front-end
application that exists over many files
and and you pack them into a single file
we call this bundling and then you ship
a single file to the browser so before
we talk about callbacks and promises a
little bit more about events let me let
me tell you about so if you have if if
you if you wanna when you develop your
node applications you're gonna be
editing files often right and having to
restart things is gonna be is gonna get
annoying really fast because it's a
running server right if you have a
running server so let's keep this
running a way to keep the server or any
file running is to do process the STD
end resume now this is advanced but
don't worry about it so if I have a
server that's running and I want to
change things having to restart to the
server is annoying so what you can do is
you can use tools to watch the files and
trigger or restart on save and one of
them is node 1 so we get NPM install -
dev node 1 node mom for nude monitor and
all you need to do is just switch your
node command to use node mod instead of
nodes so instead of node here
node mod and then it will auto restart
things for you when you save the files
so now that we're running with node mod
if I change the string and just
save it will automatically restart note
for me so this is handy in development
so because otherwise it's gonna be
annoying you can hate it of course there
are a few other tools you can use p.m.
to itself you there's a forever NPM
package though there's plenty of
packages to do that the thing and this
is general in terms of note in general
when you need you need a single feature
you have a lot of options to pick from
for example a web framework like Express
there are hundreds of them not not tens
hundreds of them and and and every one
of them has different advantages and
disadvantages so you're gonna you're
gonna have to make decisions on what
libraries to use and I would and there
are some guidelines on how to pick a
library but I would go for the popular
library that is maintained and tested so
try to see if libraries maintain the
tested and oh and it's responsive or
it's closing issues on github its
responding to issues on github and also
take a look at the code so don't be
afraid of the code and take a look at
how the library is written and are they
using clean code practices are they
using good things like typescript for
example that's a good sign if the
library is using typescript in its code
base that means they care about you know
tithes they care about their API all
right so this is node mom now let's talk
about callbacks and promises so I'm just
gonna kill this restart so it's a clean
exit nothing to do and what I'm going to
talk about is the callback pattern that
you're gonna see so if you have a
function that is wired for the callback
function let's let's use the execute
command so if you want to execute a
command from within your node process
you can use child processes what we call
the child process library child process
so this is how you use the child process
you just require I mean import import
something from the child process and I'm
going to talk about this syntax in just
a little bit so you import something
from child processing you use it now you
have a few things that you can import
from child process I'm gonna import the
exact method the exact methods from
child process so this exact method takes
two arguments or three I don't I'm not
sure we'll check the API if we need to
the first argument is the command to be
executed
so let's LS / right this is the command
to be executed so I'm gonna execute LS /
from within node from within node and it
gives you access to the output through a
callback so this is the callback that it
will invoke so in here you get a
function so the callback is just a
function I'm using arrow functions here
but you can use a regular one and I
think it gives access to out and error
I'm not sure maybe it gives X so I have
no idea what the API is but the
documentation to the rescue so let's go
look up child processes child processes
and go for exec what is the API for
exact command options callback so you
need to get comfortable reading by the
way this this weird syntax that they use
for documentation so this weird syntax
means this exact command takes the
command which is a string and then it
takes an optional options so these
square brackets around options mean
they're optional and also it takes an
optional callback and the options is an
object so you can skip it the callback
is a function and these are the three
arguments that you get their STD Adam
st-pierre I would name them exactly the
same so error STD out STD air these are
the things that you get now I'm not
focusing about the API itself what I
want to focus on is the callback
mechanism in here so if I'm interested
in the output I just do STD out right so
if I execute this file with NPM start
because it's why are we
some and everything then we will get a
module not found child
process as a child processes child
process
oh I misspelled it so its child process
and check it out
boom I see the LS / the output of that
last slash you see that so x AK executed
LS slash and then it gave me access to
the SD be out now if the command have
STD error it will give me access to us
TV error instead but why do we have two
errors there's an error here and then
there is an STD in here and the reason
is this error is related to the callback
itself not to the command right so it
depends on how you deal with it but the
callback pattern in general is that
there's always an error first argument
this is the callback pattern this is
what happens if we have an error in
executing the command not an actual
error from STD error itself not an
because every command might also result
in an error right every every string
that you pass in here might result in an
error in that case you get it an STD air
but also exec itself
might might have an error maybe it's
executing a command over as SSH and
network is slow so there's plenty of
ways for a command to fail so you always
get this error first argument and you
have to handle it because if you don't
handle it
the error is uh swallowed them it's not
cached
it's not cached and that means you have
a bug so because the command is gonna
continue to run STD out will probably be
undefined and because he did not handle
the error so you always have to handle
the air what do you want to do if there
is an error right what do you want to do
if there's an error and depends on how
this module is used you have to do
something you can for example throw
there this is the safest thing you can
do is throw the error again because if
you don't it's not again it's not cached
at all and it will
just go silent but throwing an error
will make that process will make the
error poeple up to the consumer of this
of this module you can also say you know
what if there's an error here something
serious
it happened and I don't know and I
didn't want to risk it I'm gonna process
that exit
I'm gonna make the process crash on exit
because I don't know what happened so
I'm gonna make it crash and exit with a
status code of 1 which means this is not
a clean exit we don't know what happened
and error happened and let's just crash
and exit because you don't want to have
a process running in an unknown state
and when you get an error you kind of
have an unknown state because you don't
know what there is if you want to handle
some kind of error you can you can have
an if statement here it says oh if the
error is kind of this kind you know one
kind or another kind if the error is
file not found or command not found I'm
gonna deal with it right but otherwise
process and exit this is how you handle
error you should crash the process and
exit and then the monitor is gonna start
a new process that does not have this
error state all right so this is the
error first the error first callback
signature is that the callback itself is
the last argument to the host function
so we call this the host function right
it might have a series of commands and
then the callback is a function that is
the last parameter for that the function
is gonna receive it so it's the the last
parameter for that function and then the
callback itself has three parameters
error STD out and STD I mean at least at
least one parameter which is error and
then you get the data through the second
and the third and the fourth parameter
if if they exist right so it's we call
this pattern the error first callback
pattern and this is what existed in node
since day one and it's still and it's
still supported today but there is a
different pattern today which is to use
promises instead of this callback
mechanism
so if exec was a promised based function
then this is how you would use it you
would say exact and you give it the
command LS right and this gives you back
the SDV act just like that just as if it
was not asynchronous the reason we
needed callback here is because exact is
asynchronous it needs to go to the
operating system instruct the operating
system to do something and then take
results from when the operating system
is done which might be a few seconds
later and then do something with the
results so this is an asynchronous
function so it's not synchronous I
cannot just I cannot I cannot do that I
cannot call it synchronously I have to
call it asynchronously
but if exact is promise based then I can
await or first let's do that then
I can do dot then yeah let's just do a
wait so I'm not gonna like we don't have
time to talk about that then and you
should really just use awake anyway so
you just await on exact but to await on
a function you have to wrap it in an
async function so you would do you would
like define a main function for example
and you label it as async right and then
you call the main function because this
is a thing so you cannot just await on
something you have to await on something
inside an async function but this is a
cleaner than the other part here the
other callback mechanism here because
callback has many problems and the
probably the most famous problem is how
when you start making operations depend
on each other you would have to start
nest callbacks so you would nest
callback to in callback one you would
nest callback three in callback - and we
call this the Pyramid of doom
you know the callback help problem but
that's not really the most important
problem at that callbacks the most
important problem about callbacks
is that you lose control when you have
when you do things in a callback because
unless you have trust in the system
unless you have trust that exact is
gonna actually invoke the call
one time right then you don't have
control you don't know exact might call
your callback five times I don't know
you don't have control over that while
here you have a little bit more control
you have a little bit more trust that
this exact is a promise and because it's
a promise it's gonna either resolve or
reject and it's gonna resolve or reject
only once so by moving it into a promise
based API you have a little bit more
trust into how this API is gonna behave
and this is especially important if
you're using something that's not
built-in not exact if you're using
something from Express to not built-in
so you're really relying on the
maintainer zuv Express package the
people who are wrote the code for the
Express package you're depending on
their coding skills right and you never
know but if they give you the interface
as a promise then you get back a little
bit more trust because you know the
promise is an echo script you know a
built in JavaScript thing that is going
to either resolve or reject and it will
do that either of these once so you have
a little bit more trust and also you
have a little bit more control into the
flow of the program you get STD out and
you can do something after a speedy out
and if you want to nest dependencies you
can just do them in line you don't have
to nest callback functions you happen
you don't have to do anything so it's
much cleaner and better way to just
handle asynchronous in general so here's
my advice to me unless you have to deal
with something that only supports
callbacks and nothing else
do not use callbacks always use promises
now here's the thing exact is not a
promise based function so this will not
work if we try to console the log STD
out it will not work because because
actually no it did not work it gives me
an error here a big error and I did not
handle the error right you remember that
I did not handle the error so in here I
got some kind of object child process
it's not really the output them
interested in
so how do you make it how do you promise
if I this how do you make it into a
promise well luckily note has a tool
it's called
you tell you tells you tells liking so
if this comes built-in and one of the
utilities the utility functions is is
promise if I so you can call you tells
the promise of I and you pass an exact
and it gives you back a promise fight
version of exact so we can make it like
exactly the promise version in here
right and in here since we have a
promise of I'd version of exact now we
can use the promise if I'd version of
exact and things will work fine unless
you tells is it you tell yeah there you
go so we got STD out it looks like it
returns back an object so it's util not
utils it returns back an object right
and this object has STD out and it has
STV error right so if you have an object
like this and you want to extract the
STD out all you need to do is destructor
the STD out and now we're back into the
same the same thing that's be beyond
cool
now what about STD air and air so STD
air is just another one so if you want
STD error you get it here STD error if
you want error itself that's a special
case because now we're using a promise
that means we have to we have to use the
promise API to work with error so we can
we can do that we can do dot catch in
here because this is a promise and this
will give you access to the air or you
can do the following you can use
javascript native error caching
mechanism you put everything in a
try-catch statement so you put your code
in a try-catch statement and this will
give you access to the error that
happens when you execute stuff so in
here you would do something with there
and here you will process the exit if if
you catch something that you
know that you're you know you're
unfamiliar with or or just throw it
again report it and throw it and ignore
it whatever you want to do with the
error right so this API is better on so
many levels and and again the the the
two main important levels here are trust
and control but also imagine that you
want to do asynchronous calls in in a
loop like if you want to do a loop and
every iteration of the loop you have to
do an asynchronous call if you're doing
it with callbacks it gets ugly because
you have to define the boundaries of
your loop manually you have to keep it
counter and and and check the counter to
do things in the loop but if you want to
do the asynchronous operation that is
promise based in a loop all you have to
do is just stick it inside the loop and
things will just work so there are many
benefits now some api's
are promised by default right so every
light every decent library out there now
supports promises right including node
itself node itself is going to support
promises so you would do something like
slash promises for example and it will
give you a version that support promises
out-of-the-box now they're working on
that the the FS the FS module for
example have a promise based API so if
you look up the FS module which is
something that you need to explore which
is have to work with the file system in
node so if you look up FS in here
fastest them how to read files and write
to files and create copy files and
rename files and delete directories this
is the biggest module in node right and
it is the most used module because we
work with files a lot right but if you
look at it you'll see that it has a
promises API so you don't even need to
promise if I things you get promises out
of the box and and many other libraries
support both callbacks and promises they
support callbacks for backwards
compatibility but they also
promises because that's that's the
direction where we're going with
asynchronous with asynchronous calls now
if you notice I didn't really use the
promised API I didn't do dot Ven or duck
catch I just used async await right
because it's just so much better
dot then so the promise it sells gives
you back the trust but async away gives
you much better flow control so you flow
your your your code in in a better way
you control what happens with your code
so you and you don't need to nest
functions right so there's much benefits
to async await so that is it about
callbacks and promises so if you have
any questions about that shoot up now
callback some promises both of them
really are limited in terms of handling
handling multiple events right handling
multiple events so there are there this
is appropriate here because we have a
single event this asynchronous nature
here is a single event that we need to
execute a single command and get back a
single output right but what if we have
like a monitor of commands what if we
are monitoring the memory for example
right we're monitoring the memory this
application is using we would need to
pull many commands on an interval we
need we need many events right or we're
monitoring the memory and we're
interested in knowing what's gonna
happen when it reaches certain
thresholds like after 100 me 200 me
right so if you have an asynchronous
operation that has multiple events this
is where you need to use an event
emitter you need to use an event emitter
and using an event emitter is
straightforward because it comes it's
supported in node itself so this is this
is something that you need to get
familiar with you import event emitter
from events this is also built-in you
import event in metal from events and
you create an event emitter an event a
matter object using this syntax new
event
emitter and now you can if it emit
events you can say okay FET the matter
I'm going to emit this event just let's
call it change something has changed you
can you can omit any event right you can
omit the same event multiple times right
and to listen on these events and do
something you just do the on method just
like the server because the server is an
event Mary you just do on change and
what do you want to do on change well
let's just console.log something has
changed right console.log something has
changed so this is the syntax for event
emitting right now here's your interview
question what's gonna happen when I
execute this code and your answer is
will I see this three times because I
emitted three times and then I'm
listening to the unchanged event and the
answer is no you will not see it at all
why because I started listening after I
emitted the three events right I started
listening after I emitted the three
events and the order here matters so if
we change the order to put the listen
first listen and then emit three times
then you'll see something has changed
three times so the order matter in fact
everything here is synchronous there's
nothing asynchronous yet however what
you can do is you can start emitting
things asynchronously
for example let's do let's do a set
interval and emit something has changed
every second right now we have set
interval that runs every second and in
here we can you know emit some emit
event event emitter dot emit change
right so in here now what's gonna happen
is if something has changed is gonna be
emitted every second and our handler is
gonna call it our handler is gonna be
called so this is our handler basically
we're handling this event by just
constant logging it right so this is
what you use if you have
multiple events going on you would use
an event emitter and here's the thing
everything in node is based on this
event emitter logic so when you get an
HTTP server or when you get a stream
right if they're all event emitting
object right so the you remember when we
did server get and we did that and we
get request and response right we did
request and response and we did
something with request and response
guess what
server is an event emitter request is an
event emitter response is an event
emitter they all have events and you can
listen to these events and you can make
them emit events right can we make the
emitter use async/await instead of a
callback yes you can in fact this is
supported if we the not async/await in
general but an event emitter is also can
be consumed as a generator because this
is this ties into the generator concept
in JavaScript right because JavaScript
has this generator concept so if you
wanna if you wanna look that out if you
want more information about that look up
generators in in JavaScript and have to
consume new event emitter objects in
node through the generators and X all
right so this is all the time we have
for events I'm gonna try to cover a few
more topics in modern JavaScript but
definitely keep that questions coming
because I know there's a lot of
information here I just want you to dick
to get a taste of everything that you
can do in node and really tease your
knowledge into the the capabilities that
you have built in before even installing
anything like Express or lodash the
other big thing that you need to learn
here before I switch gears into the
modern JavaScript just review is streams
so you need to learn about streams in
node and streams are big in them so what
what are streams in general so streams
are like they're kind of
like array of data but instead of having
this data over space you have it over
time right so it's not available all at
once it's not available for you in
memory you're just getting it over time
so every time you have a chunk we call
it a chunk right a chunk of data becomes
available and you can use it in your
stream and after a while you get another
chunk of data and you can use it in your
stream so what our stream is good for
they're good if you have huge amounts of
data that you need to process in your
code if you need to process a huge
amount of data in your code you have to
do it with streams but here's the thing
here's the general advice I'm gonna give
you you should just use streams all the
time even if you have to process small
amounts of data because they because you
never know when the data is going to
grow and you never know what's gonna
happen in that case
so streams are basically just like pipes
yes and you can pipe streams on each
other so an example of handling data
that you should do through streams is
the HTTP example for requests are asking
for an image right if a requester is
asking for a file in general you should
really use streams to handle that you
should read the file as a stream and
write the file as a stream so when you
do that your application will not
consume the size of the file in memory
so let's say you're you're trying to
serve a 1 gigabyte video file in your
web server right if you don't use
streams you will buffer one gigabyte of
data in memory and that's how much
memory your node process is gonna
consume but if you're using streams you
can get these chunks you know 660
kilobyte at a time or whatever the
default chunk size is and you get chunk
one chunk and stream it to the requester
and they get to play while your stream
binary data because it's supported right
video streaming is supported but this is
how you do it you stream at one
chunk at a time you do not send the
whole thing you do not buffer the whole
thing you do not send the whole thing
now note comes stream ready out of the
box so the note the note HTTP package is
stream ready because everything is
streams and all the wrappers around it
our streams ready so when you do duck
send file for example in Express Express
is gonna do the right thing and stream
it you just need to be aware that you're
dealing with streams you're not dealing
with buffers you're dealing with streams
in general and and when you run into
problems you'll run into stream related
problems right you have to be aware of
that so if you get any errors about
chunks and you know stream interrupted
or one stream is slower than the other
right because if a stream is slower than
if the sending stream is lower than the
receiving stream then the streams have
to do it have to do some you know back
pressure kind of thing so there's a lot
of science around streams you just need
to know that you're dealing with streams
all the time you can also create your
own streams in node using the stream
package that comes built-in and you also
get streams out of the box for example
there is the zip package there is the
crypto package that you get in node and
these have functions that work with
streams so if you want to gzip something
or unzip something if you want to
encrypt or decrypt something you get to
do it with streams because all of these
work on can work on large data you never
know if the thing that you want to
encrypt is small or big if it's bigger
than you know a few megabytes you should
definitely use stream this is why by
default you should use stream so there
are a few types of stream but the most
important the most interesting type is
the transform stream the transform
stream so there's readwrite there is
duplex stream but really the most
interesting type is the transform stream
which is what you get when you use the
zip and crypto is where you get one
source one readable source and you write
to a writable destination so you read
from a readable source
and you write a writable destination we
call these transform streams all right
cool
the other thing that I want you to
explore and I'm gonna give you some
resources at the end for what's next but
the other thing that you want to explore
is scaling in general so how to scale a
node application because if you can't
scale another application you should not
be right you should not be running milli
right node has scalability out of the
box like built-in and the way it does
this is through the cluster module so
the cluster module gives you a way to
load balance a few processes together
and you should always run your node
application in production under a
cluster you should not run a single
process even if your server is only
capable of running a single process that
single process should be a cluster so
your server is gonna have is gonna run
as many processes as it has a virtual
cores right so you so for example this
machine and we can look at the virtual
cores here using OS the CPUs which is a
function dot link so this particular Mac
machine has 12 cores
right which means I can run 12 note
processes and the operating system is
gonna be fine with it right and they all
can run in parallel so if I'm running a
production server here I would have a
cluster of 12 processes all running the
same thing and I would have a load
balancer that balanced between them and
the same process is gonna monitor 12
processes and it will automatically
start a new process if one crashes and
we can also do a zero downtime restart
by restarting one process at a time so
we're worst at one process and wait
until that process finishes any pending
requests you know and then when it's
done we'll start a replacement so we
call this zero downtime restart so
there's plenty of things that you can do
and you can do it all through the
cluster module but it's kind of like the
story of
you know HTTP and Express you know the
raw versus rich API so instead of
cluster you can use the PM to package or
something similar PM 2 is just one of
the one of my favorite packages and this
is what we use in J's complete it is a
wrapper around the cluster module and it
gives you rich features out of the box
with just a few commands so that's not
only take a look at PM - if you want to
run a node application in production I
would strongly recommend that you
started with PN - so we just take a
quick look at the big list that we
started with and see if we missed
anything important I'll mention a few
things here but I I kind of want to show
you the inspection it's important how
you debug new applications so this is
this is definitely on the list but I'll
mention a few things here DNS if you
want to do DNS enquiries eval something
should never use write this actually
it's JavaScript path if you want to work
with you know paths on the operating
system so if you want to look up a file
you need to specify a path however paths
are gonna be different on Windows than
they are on Linux and Mac so if you want
to do it in an operating system agnostic
way you do it through the path the path
module here read line if you need to
actually write a CLI command then you
need to take input from the user you can
use this read line method there are few
utilities that we didn't cover but
really it util is kind of going away
because things are coming natively to
the language right so util was just a
replacement but there's definitely a few
things that you can do here what's what
else what else crypto domain don't use
that events again is the most important
net we didn't really talk about net and
net is big so that if you want to do any
TCP programming in node if you want to
do TCP communication and socket
communication you would use this
built-in net library if you
interface with v8 you can use v8 this
this package v8 gives you a few methods
to access v8 directly assert is
something that you get out of the box
which is kind of like a very mini
assertion library that you can use in
your tests so this would replace this is
just like chai for example it has a few
built in assertions that you can use FS
is huge right this is the file system OS
is read information from the operating
system stream if you want to create
streams not if you want to use them if
you want to create streams you would use
this stream package string decoder if
you are using binary information and you
want to decode it into a string you
would use this one Z Lib if you want to
zip things and unzip things oh this is
all built-in you don't install anything
this is all built-in power right which
is really great
and finally query string and URL if you
want to work with with parson and format
URLs all right so there's plenty of
things for you to to learn you got yeah
you kind of have to learn like the
capabilities of all these packages and
of course I skipped everything
JavaScript but there's a lot of
JavaScript in here I want to show you
how to debug a node application so let's
say that we have
we have an array and we wanna a map and
like be equal aid up map and in here
let's say we want to function and in
here we want to return e times e so some
kind of some kind of code that we need
to debug right and console the log B so
this this debugging thing that I'm gonna
show you is gonna work no matter what
even if you have a server running you
can debug node with with the following
so if I'm running this server node
server that is cool things are worth
working so we have a bug here like we're
passing a plus B instead of star we
don't know like what is going on and I
need to debug what is going on why is it
not doubling the elements instead of why
is it doubling the elements instead of
squaring them and I need to debug that
so what I can do is I can run node with
inspect you just do note inspect just
like that node inspect server dodged as
a sorry node - - inspect server digest -
- inspect surfer that yes and this will
this will run the file through the
inspector but this file does not run
forever right because it does not run
forever it will exit so although we run
it through the inspector we also exited
and the inspector accident so what you
can do is instead of - - inspect do - -
inspect BRK which means inspect and
break on the first line so don't don't
exit inspect and break on the first line
so what this does is it will create a
WebSocket server listening on this URL
and you can use a dev tool kind of tool
to connect to this web socket and issue
commands for node to you know break on a
breakpoint or go to the next line or go
you know jump over step over a function
the thing is chrome support this out of
the box all you need to do is go to
chrome inspect and it will see all the
listening processes right here so you
see my node server that justice right
here all I need to do is click inspect
and it will give me ready for a dev
tools for my node script right there and
I can do everything I can do in the dev
tools that I use with my you know
front-end application I can resume
script execution step over go here step
in to inspect the variables local in
this case is one and then step next one
he is two and the return value is that
everything that you have in the very
rich dev tools experience you can use it
with node just with the dash dash
inspect or dash dash inspect BRK and you
can set breakpoints and set expressions
call stack watch expressions everything
right so how cool is that right very
very very cool and every time you pause
in here you can do manual operations on
on the variables that you have so this
is inspection with with nodes just use
the that just use the chrome dev tools
integration with the dash dash inspect
now if you need to inspect a node
application on like a server where you
don't have a graphical interface you can
use the dash you can use the inspect
itself so if you just do inspect not - -
inspect if you just do inspect you get a
terminal debugger so you can debug here
in the terminal and you see how it
stopped on the debugger one I thought I
had it stopped right here and you can
debug everything you can go into I think
you can have to type rebel and now you
can debug things in in the rebel and you
can type in and you can control see to
exit the rebel type and help to see what
you can do in here you can have commands
to break point and continue and
and watch things and all the this so we
call this a terminal debugger and it's
handy if you're debugging things in
production on a server where you don't
have a graphical user interface and
there's a case where it only happens in
that server and it you can't reproduce
it locally so that terminal debugger is
something that you can use as well all
right cool
so there is a lot of modern JavaScript
that you need to to learn if you if you
want to work with node projects and the
reason you need to learn these modern
JavaScript is that everyone is using
them so you look at any node based
project and the project that is gonna be
you know any if you're if you want to
join a team they're probably using
modern JavaScript now I wrote a lot
about modern JavaScript I'm gonna try
and find the three article so in the J's
complete library jobs I think it's
JavaScript for react all the jobs you
need to use before react so I wrote this
for react but it really applies to
everything so I am kind of like focusing
on and this is free you can just read it
here I just complete I'm focusing on the
features that are specific to react but
for node you need all of this and more
so that is the whole subset that you
need to learn so I'm just gonna go over
really quick and just mention what's
important what's really important in
modern JavaScript that you need to know
block scopes are good not very important
oh that we have a list here arrow
functions yes we use this all the time
they are a little bit different but
what's important for you to understand
is how they behave in terms of closures
right so error functions and closure and
this is this article is your first good
step into understanding these but you
get an expand on that after that literal
notation not really new but we we do a
lot of stuff expressions destructuring
another big one here is these
structuring so I'm gonna quickly tell
you about it so this is the D
structuring syntax that we have here
this we use D structuring with arrays
and objects and so this is what Airways
this is with objects destructuring with
objects and its really equivalent to
doing this here so the D structure in
ovaries is equivalent to what I did here
you just take the items as they are
positioned in the array and you give
them local names in the scope in the
local scope you give them names in your
local scopes and that works for object
properties and array items by their
position right so very very very big we
use destruction all the time because
it's a much better syntax you can also
use it in function parameters so you can
D structure a function parameter if that
parameter is an object or an array you
can D structure the properties that
you're interested in right there inside
the function parentheses where you
define the parameters of the function
alright spread and rest the three dots
operator the three dot syntax here is
magic if you use it with destructuring
like this it's a rest operator basically
you're capturing the rest of the array
elements after the structuring the first
one into another array so you use it to
capture part of an array or an object
and you can also use it later on to
spread an array into another array so in
here the three dot operator is spreading
array one in two array two and
introducing more items into already do
and I'm spreading object two into
another object you spread one object
into another object cool so this is this
is the spread syntax another important
things is promises and async await so I
told you a little bit about it this is
more details here about promises and
async await and we also talked about
module important export a little bit
more details here about named imports
and named exports and default imports
and default experts and the rest of this
article here is just not modern
JavaScript but more geared toward react
so in react we use a lot map filter and
reduce we use conditional expressions
and we if you need to use timers you
would need to use set time and set
intervals there's some examples here
about that
so I do want to leave a few minutes for
any last-minute questions but I'm gonna
give you a little bit more what's next
so I have this is not completely free
but I'm writing but I think parts of it
are so I'm writing this complete intro
to node.js which is going to be a mini
book for for you to start with nodejs it
covers a lot of what we cover today in
more details so this is a good next step
if you want to venture into that and
after that I have the node beyond the
basics book which is gonna be a huge one
I'm still working on that so it will
hopefully be published in in the next
few months but this is really the
advanced book after you're done with
just the basics this is what are you
actually gonna learn no this is where
you learn the modules and the
event-driven architecture in the stream
that a child process and how to scale
will cluster so deep dive into the node
concepts that we mentioned today and
there are a lot of them there's a lot of
details now you can learn all of this
through the official documentation just
read the API documentation in fact this
is how I learned stuff is just by
reading the documentation in here and
the examples are not too bad it's just
when you when you put big things
together and work through the context
example that you relate to it's a lot
easier to learn so that's what I'm doing
in the next few months is I am fleshing
out the beyond the basics book to have
like one place where you can learn all
the advanced stuff about node runtime
itself not note packages but no runtime
itself so I don't cover things like
Express or lodash or socket IO I don't
cover any packages I'm just focusing on
what you get built in out-of-the-box
with node and the capabilities that that
gives you so you can build your systems
on top of them because if you can avoid
introducing a new package to your
dependencies you should so you should
not really bring in low - just to summon
array because you can summon array in
three in two lines of in one line of
code in
in modern JavaScript right so you should
avoid getting a dependency unless like
your whole system is designed around
that dependency for example you're using
react you would have react as a
dependency but think so many times
before you introduce the dependency and
if you can do it natively you should do
it natively first all right cool
so we're coming to an end so I'm gonna
leave some time for questions so if you
have any final last minute questions now
is the time we've got seven minutes left
so we have we can we can handle that so
I'll give you a few minutes to type any
questions that you have and I'll see
which bits of JavaScript should you
avoid if in node if possible oh man that
is a big question so what should you
avoid in node and the answer is not
there's nothing special in node you
should avoid bad JavaScript and
JavaScript has a lot of bad parts right
now modern JavaScript solved many of
these bad parts right so you don't
really have to deal with them but you
should for example always use strict
right so this is one thing so use strict
is important so if you go in here by
default node does not use strict by
default so I can define a variable
without var for example and that's bad
you should not do that you should not be
able to define a variable without far
because JavaScript is gonna do the
hoisting thing and confuse your code so
this should not be allowed and you can
put use strict in your in your files
just use strict and this will make you
know the strict mode this will activate
the strict mode out-of-the-box for you
but a better way to just adding this use
strict everywhere is just to instruct
node to always use strict and you
there's a flag for that you can just do
- - use strict and this flag is actually
v8 so if you do - - use strict and you
try to define a variable with that far
that tells you you cannot do that a is
not defined what are you doing if you
want to define a variable you
war or consulate right so this is a form
of protection against bad practices in
JavaScript is to always use strict and
if you're using a bundler like for
example if you're using babel by default
babel is gonna use strict for you so or
if you're using typescript for example
you can tell type scripts you always use
strict all the time assume strict mode
and type scripts gonna give you errors
into using type scripts into using a
non-standard or like bad practices in
fact i would definitely advise you to
explore typescript next because
typescript is gives you a huge value but
the problem is it also comes with a lot
of package for you basically that you
need to you need to deal with types you
need to deal with missing tags you have
to define you have to add write extra
code but give it a few weeks not a few
days give typescript a few weeks and
after a few weeks of working with
typescript you're gonna see the value
typescript is on is next on my list of
things to write about
so we use typescript at JS complete and
it is a huge value for us so in fact my
next Pluralsight course might be on
typescript and now definitely there will
be in the future a book about typescript
so try to use the good practices and try
to have a type checker in your system
but there's also es lint es lint is big
so if you can't use typescript if it's a
big decision for you just start with es
lint and start with recommended rules
for your system so es let is another
code quality tool that you can use and
it's it integrates into your editor so
if you do something bad es lint is going
to complain right away in your editor
and it can also auto fix bad problems
some bad problems for you so definitely
take a look at es lint and configure
your system to have you know the
amended rules like for example a
recommended rule is to always use
semicolons this is recommended rule you
should not write your javascript without
semicolons unless you have in your flow
something that will fix that most cases
for you and warn you if you do you know
if you if you do something like this
because javascript is gonna assume you
want to do that without a semicolon
right so definitely yes lint is
something that needs to be in your flow
even if you're using typescript right es
length is just a different different
category of protection against you know
what you should not be using in your
code so I'm gonna stop at this point
thank you all for attending and see you
in other sessions